I want a that something bill clinton
said yesterday he he seemed to compare
your your supporters and your movement
to the tea party
he said the tea party leaders just told
people what they wanted to hear they
didn't get anything done and they were
politically polarizing and he said
that's what's going on in our party now
i'm wondering where you think of the
comparison between you and the tea party
well i think it's unfortunate i think
some of the things that President
Clinton has been saying are unfortunate
I do understand obviously he's trying to
do his best to get his wife to win the
nomination and become president I
understand that my wife is doing her
best to try to get me to become
president but we should not be making
silly remarks is there a comparison no
there's local just under quid the
question again we've discussed it with
you before this skepticism that you're
you're telling people things that they
want to hear but the people what they
want to hear people want jobs they want
health care they want educational
opportunities for their kids they want
to deal with climate change they want
the wealthiest people to pay their fair
share of taxes yeah that's what I'm
telling people and on every one of those
issues that is exactly what the American
people want now what the right wing says
is what the American people really want
is to cut Social Security and give tax
breaks to billionaires and cut Medicare
and Medicaid and by the way according to
the right-wing climate change is a hoax
the difference is what I tell people is
what I believe to be true what is true
and you check the issues you look at the
polling do the people want the
wealthiest folks in this country to
start paying their fair share of taxes
you know what establishment may not like
that it is true do people think that we
should make public colleges and
universities tuition-free yes they do
should we raise the minimum wage yeah
that's what the American people want so
what we are doing is maybe saying to the
American people it's about time that the
Congress listened to you and your needs
and your demands so just to put a button
on this is fair to say you would reject
Bill Clinton's comparison I think it's
fair to say